I was appointed as Goodwill Ambassador for UN Women six months ago...
...and the more I've spoken about feminism,...
...the more I have realized that fighting for women's rights...
...has too often become synonymous with man-hating.
If there is one thing I know for certain, it is that this has to stop.
For the record, feminism by definition...
...is the belief that men and women should have equal rights and opportunities.
It is the theory of the political, economic and social equality of the sexes.
I started questioning gender-based assumptions a long time ago,...
...when I was eight, I was confused at being called "bossy"...
...because I wanted to direct the plays that we would put on for our parents...
...but the boys were not.
When at 14, I started to be sexualized by certain elements of the media.
When at 15, my girlfriends started dropping out of their beloved sports teams...
...because they didn't want to appear "muscly".
When at 18, my male friends were unable to express their feelings.
I decided that I was a feminist and this seemed uncomplicated to me.
But my recent research has shown me that feminism has become an unpopular word.
Women are choosing not to identify as feminists.
Apparently, I am among the ranks of women whose expressions...
...are seen as too strong, too aggressive, isolating, and anti-men.
Unattractive even.
Why has the word become such an uncomfortable one?